عشرات المسلسلات بتشارك في الموسم
الرمضاني هذه السنه مختلف المواضيع
والفئات والقصص وحقيقه يعني معظمها لها
جمهورها والناس المتابعه لها لكن لو
حنتكلم عن مسلسل واحد متصدر عربيا فما
بنبالغ لو قلنا انه جعفر العمده هذا العمل
اللي من بطوله محمد رمضان ومجموعه من
النجوم ومن تاليف واخراج المخرج النجم
ايضا محمد سامي واللي يعتبر او يعتبر هذا
تعاونه الثالث مع محمد رمضان في الدراما
19 سنه بقول هذه
وما فيش حاجه بتهون
وانا عملت ايه غلط في حياتي
بالاحرمني من عيال الاثنين
بسم الله
فاكره ان ربنا خلق الدنيا دي كلها عشان هو
بس
انت ورثت
كل حكايه الجواز دي
وقفت قدام اهلي بعت كل حاجه في الدنيا
عشان خاطره
الخط العزف ابني انا مش عارف اعيش عايزه
اكمل الحكايه للاخر لو الواد عايش رجعه لي
ولو ميت ورينا فين عارفه مين اللي خده
[موسيقى]
فعليا كل حلقه ترند واحداث شاغله الناس
لحظه بلحظه ومقعدتهم مستنيين كل حلقه
بحلقتها هذا غير الشخصيات الرهيبه والجمل
اللي معلقه مع الناس يعني عمل متكامل
وبيثبت فيه محمد سامي انه الرقم الصعب في
الاخراج
وفي ظهور ما بيحصل كثير محمد سامي منورنا
اليوم في تفاعلكم اهلا فيك معنا محمد وكل
عام وانت بالف خير يا رب
اهلا وسهلا بك وكل سنه وانت طيبه وبخير يا
رب ورمضان كريم عليك وعلى كل المشاهدين
الكرام طيب يعني ما اكون ببالغ صراحه لو
اقول لك انه نحن كلنا هنا بنتابع جعفر
العمده الصراحه يعني ومستنيين الحلقه
بحلقه وكل يوم حتى بنحكي مع بعض انه صفصف
قالت كده ثريا قالت كده وكل ده الكلام انت
ايش اللي خلاك من البدايه يعني تدخل في
هذه القصه ايش اللي حبيت تقوله
والله انا انا يعني في في كذا طريقه ببني
بها المسلسل انا بشوف دايما اني من زمان
في قصص معينه وفي مواضيع معينه في
اتموسفير معين هو بيكون انجح عربيه ومصريا
في في الدراما التلفزيونيه يعني دلوقتي في
منعطف اخر لشكل الحلقات الدراميه للبلات
فورس والحاجات الجديده ولكن شكل شهر رمضان
بشكل المسلسل الدراما الرمضاني من زمان
جدا وهو الدراما المصريه لها اشكال كتير
بس في شكل ثابت رئيسي هو اللي بيكون اقرب
للجمهور او اقرب الاشتياق الجمهور لرمضان
وهي الحاره المصريه الحاره المصريه اللي
هي الحاره الشعبيه اللي فيها الوصول وفيها
القيم وفيها المبادئ ومن ناحيه ثانيه فيها
التناقضات وفيها الصراعات فيها فيها مجتمع
كامل الحاله المصريه فيها مجتمع كامل هو
عمره ما بيخلص وعمره ما هيخلص من الحواديت
ومن القصص فدي اهم حاجه انا ببص عليها
دايما يعني لما جيت اعمل قصه جعفر لعمده
بعد كده شاركني السيناريو والحوار مهاب
طارق وانا من الاول واول حاجه قلتها
للراجل قلت له احنا احنا جوه الموت ده
احنا جوه الشكل ده احنا جوه البيت المصري
اللي في مصر وفي الوطن العربي بيحبوا
يتفرجوا عليه وعلى احداثه ومن هنا طلع
منطق الاتموسيه اللي اتعمل فيه جعفر
العمده بالنسبه للي عايز اقول ايه ضعف
العمده انا اتفضل
اللي انا عايز اقوله بجعفر العمده انا
بشوف ان المسلسل ال 30 حلقه بيكون
في مجال مش بكون حاجه واحده او مش بكون
بفكر في حاجه واحده عايز اقولها بيبقى فيه
طبعا رئيسيه وبيبقى فيه موضوع رئيسي انا
انا بمنشن فيه الفكره بتاعتي ولكن انا
شايف ان المسلسل بيتخلله رسائل كثيره جدا
وبيكون في افكار كتير جدا الواحد عايز
يطرحها ليها علاقه بالاخلاق ولها علاقه
بالتعاملات المجتمعيه ولها علاقه
بالاحترام وليها علاقه بالانتماء الاسري
ولها علاقه بحاجات كتير جدا من اكتر
الحاجات اللي انا بحب ادوس عليها دايما في
المسلسلات هي البرور مثلا فكره البرور
بالاسره فكره البرور الام والاب
دي دي بكون حاجه قيمه عايز افكر الناس
بيها خاصه في شهر رمضان وبكل ناس قريبه
بيفطروا على موائد في بيوت بعض في بيوت
اهلهم فبحب احيي القيم دي يعني طول الوقت
في مسلسلاتي من اول مسلسل لغايه مسلسل
جعفر العمده
محمد يعني الرائعه مي كساب يعني وصفتك
قالت انك انت مخرج الشعب يعني وانت قلت
انك انت يعني وصلت للتوليفه اللي بيفهموا
فيها او بتفهم فيها انه الناس ايش حابه
انت الان شرحت توليفتك بكل بساطه وبكل ثقه
ما بتخاف انه يدخلوا عليك ناس ويعملوا نفس
التوليفه وينافسوك
اصل هي مش بالعكس المنافسين احنا مفيش حد
في الدنيا لوحده ربنا سبحانه وتعالى خلق
الدنيا لكل الناس ما هو كل الناس عارفه
اني يعني كل الناس اتفرجت مثلا على على
على شخص عمل فيسبوك ليه مش كل الناس عملته
كل الناس اتفرجت على شخص عمل تسلا ليه مش
كل الناس عملته يعني في في هي كل الناس
عارفه التوليفه وكل الناس بتسعى دائما ان
هي تعمل التوليفه لاقرب
لرغبه الجمهور بس اللي بيوصل لها مش
الاشطر على فكره او كده بيصلي ربنا سبحانه
وتعالى بيدي له بصيره او فتوح من عنده لان
هو احنا في الاخر ربنا سبحانه وتعالى هو
اساس كل حاجه وهو ده
على الله سبحانه وتعالى اكيد التوفيق بس
اكيد بتشوف نفسك الافضل انت كمان يا محمد
يعني كمان اكيد بتشوف نفسك الافضل والله
انا بشوف اني انا الحمد لله ربي كرمني
واهلي راضيين عني عشان كده الحمد لله رب
العالمين ربنا وفقني الحمد لله ولله الحمد
خليني انقلك على موضوع كثير ناس بيتكلموا
عنه انك انت بتوصل لمرح له انك انت بتكتب
وبتخرج في نفس الوقت مو متعب هذا الشيء
بالنسبه لك يعني لو مثلا جبت احد كاتب لك
السيناريو وخلاص انت ركزت في الاخراج
والله بصي هقول لحضرتك على حاجه انا بحسب
انا اتمنى دايما ان يكون في سكريبت حلو
جدا جايلي وابذل مجهود كمخرج لان انا في
الاصل انا مخرج ولكن انا بيكون عندي حاجه
انا عايز اقدمها طول ما انا عندي حاجه
عايز اقدمها ولم يعرض علي نص هو افضل من
اللي انا عايز اقدمه هو هو انا انا انا
ساعتها ليه ليه ليه مش هعمله يعني انا لما
ببص للتجارب الاخيره بتاعتي هي كانت لله
الحمد هي التجارب اللي انجح وكانت التجارب
الانجح في السيزون اللي هي موجوده فيه
متميزه على على بقيه الاعمال اللي هي في
اعمال منها عظيمه جدا ومحترمه جدا ومعظمها
محترم وجميل وزميلتي زمايلي
واساتذتي والناس كلهم اللي انا بحترمهم
وبحبهم واللي كان الحمد لله من المسلسلات
المتميزه وكانت
بتعتلي
المتصدره يعني في السيزون وانا كنت اللي
كاتبهم انا لو يعرض عليا نصي خليني اتميز
عن هذه الاعمال انا لن اتولى ان انا اعمله
في ساعتها انا اتمنى ان طول الوقت في رحله
البحث عن سكريبت جيد
ولكن ما في احد بيغلبك في السكريبت الجيد
واضح انه حتى الان انت لازلت متفوق في
السكربت الجيد
وانا بعمل انا بشتغل مشهد من الاول بعمل
المشهد بقعد قبل ما اعمل اي حاجه خالص
بقعد انا وكل الممثلين بعد ما يلبسوا
يجهزوا بميكب في وش شعرهم وكل الشخصيه
تبقى قدامي يقعدوا قدامي وابدا وانا بشرح
الميزانسين بتاع المشهد او حركه المشهد
ببدا اقرا الممثلين المشهد مره الاول قبل
ما يبداوا هم يقراوا ابدا اقرا المشهد مره
الاول وابدا وهم اما يبداوا يقروا قدامي
ابدا اقول طيب صفصف هتقولي هنا كذا طيب
جعفر هتقول هنا كذا ممكن حد من الممثلين
كمان يطلع بجمله لطيفه او بقفله لطيف ولكن
دائما ما بنبعدش عن محور المشهد بس ممكن
نحط افات لطيفه حالي
من الافهات اللي موجوده على على في
المسلسل دلوقتي هي طلعت في اللوكيشن
طلعتها في اللوكيشن واحنا قاعدين بنشتغل
والتعاون مع محمد رمضان يعني يبدو انه
كانكم مع بعض في فورمه لنجاح جميله يعني
رمضان رمضان اصل احنا خلاص دلوقتي احنا
الاتنين احنا اصحاب واخوات
وبنثق في بعض جدا وفي بالنا كمستري رهيبه
وشركاء نجاح دايما نجاحك مع الشخص بيخليكي
في بينك وبين الثقه وموده وحب واحترام
وهدوء في التفكير وكل حاجه فانا ورمضان
خلاص احنا بنشتغل دلوقتي كمان ارمي يعني
احنا بنشتغل كشخص واحد خلاص احنا مش
بنشتغل كشخصين مع بعض او حد من ان انا
عايز يفرض وجهه نظره على الثاني او حد
مننا عايز يشوش تاني احنا بالعكس احنا
بنساعد بعض طول الوقت ان احنا الاتنين في
مركب واحد عايزين نسعد الجمهور بننزل
الصبح من البيت عايزين نسعد الجمهور ونروح
عايزين نسعد الجمهور واحنا كميتنا في
التفكير في المواضيع قريبه بحد كبير جدا
لبعض ده اللي مريحنا من البدايه يعني
الان بدات الحلقات يعني طبعا خلاص كل يوم
بيتفاعلوا معاها الناس وترند وكذا كثير
ناس رجعوا شبهوا المسلسل بعائله الحجم
متولي للراحل طبعا الكبير نور الشريف الله
يرحمه بتحس في تشابه ولا هي بس فكره
الاربع زوجات يعني
هو اصل المسلسل بتاعي مش بيحكي عن الاربع
زوجات يعني هو هو في اول حاجه رحمه الله
الاول الاستاذ نور الشريف الرحمه ونقول
للناس عليه الفاتحه في شهر الفضيل ده
استاذنا الكبير اللي تعلمنا منه
والله لو الناس هتشباني باستاذ نور الشريف
فوق راسي لو الاستاذ شبهني باعمال العظماء
دول انا فوق راسي ولكن هو انا مسلسلي مش
بيحكي عن زوجه واربع نساء زي الحج متولي
انا مسلسلي بيحكي عن اب ضايع منه ابنه لما
نيجي نحكي جعفر العمده في سطر هنقول موضوع
ان راجل متجوز من اربع ستات ده مش من
المين مش المين بلس عن راجل بيدور على
ابنه وعايز يعرف مين اللي عمل فيه كده مين
اللي اجر بلال شامه عشان يخطف ابنه مش
بحكي عن شخص عنده اربع ستات وايه موضوعهم
ثاني حاجه انا انا انا كنت يعني لما جيت
عملت المسلسل انا بعرف دائما ان الناس لما
بيبقى في علامات مهمه وانت تتشابهي معاها
في بعض النقاط انا كنت منتظر الناس تقول
اكثر في الاول ان هو يشبه الحاج متولي
ولكن الفكره ما خدش الكومنت ده وقت طويل
او ما اخدش حيز من الموضوع لان كاتب الناس
اتشغلت في الموضوع يعني يمكن الحكايه دي
اتقالت لما اعلن عن فكره المسلسل في الاول
ولسه الناس ما دخلتش في تفصيله بس انا
فعلا ما حسيتش بده حتى كنت بتكلم انا
ومحمد رمضان في ده بقول له والله انا حسيت
ان الموضوع ده لم ياخذ صدى يعني هو فعلا
المسلسل مش هنا مش في المنطقه دي ولو هو
هيشبه المسلسل مع كامل الاحترام انا هاقدم
ليه مسلسل اتقدم شبهه قبل كده يعني يعني
مش من قله المواضيع او من قله الافكار
يعني هي يبدو مشهد لما انجاب لهم زينه على
البيت هو ده اللي ربط عند الناس المسلسلات
مع بعض لما هي طبعا زوجته الرابعه محمد
انا بدي استغل وجودك معانا واسالك كم سؤال
كده سريعين على بعض الاشياء المتداوله بين
الناس اذا ممكن ترد لنا عليها وتوضحها
واحده من الاشياء الكثير ناس علقوا عليها
انك انت طبعا رجعت الفنانه لبنى ونيس
صغيره ورجع طبعا محمد رمضان صغيره وصاروا
الناس بيسالوا انت جبت ممثله ثانيه
ولا ما احنا الان شايفين الصوره امامنا
على الشاشه يعني هل انت جبت ممثله ثانيه
ولا انت ايش عملت بالضبط
والله احنا عملنا دقيق انا بشتغل في
شركه محترمه جدا شركه بوست محترمه جدا هي
من او مش من هي تقريبا اكبر شركه بوست في
القاهره هي للاستاذ ياسر النجار والفريق
بتاعه العظيم شركه ميركلي ودول
احنا اما جيت من الاول عندي التصغير
للاستاذه لبنى وناس وعندي للاستاذ طارق
النهري
والمديحه البكري والاكثر والايمان العاصي
وماي كساب متصغرين وكلهم متصغرين اول حاجه
فكرنا فيها عملنا كبيره جدا والفريق
التقني وفريق الفي اف اكس والاستاذ ياسر
النجار ومش عايز اقول اسماء الناس كلها
عشان ما انساش منهم حد لان كلهم عملوا نفس
المجهود حمدان واحمد الشريف وندى وكلهم
فاحنا قعدنا وفكرنا ازاي هنعمل هنعمل ده
وقعدنا بدانا نتفرج وبدانا نشوف هنعمل
ازاي وبدانا نجيب من الافلام من هوليود
ونشوف التكنيك اللي تم استعماله وبدانا
نصور شبطات للممثلين في الاول ونبدا نجرب
عليها فالموضوع دوت بدا قبل ما نبدا
المسلسل نفسه عشان نوصل للنتيجه فلما شفت
ان الموضوع عمل ترند والناس علقت عليه في
ريحت جدا جدا لانه نتاج مجهود فعلا كان
كبير وانه كان اول مره يتعمل يعني هو اول
مره يتعمل الحمد لله في الوطن العربي وما
كنتش عايز اعمله عادي من انا اصغرهم بمجرد
ميك اب واحط ميك اب وخلاص وحبه صفطس على
الوش ما بيبقاش جربت عملت ده قبل كده بس
مكنتش مبسوط
بجد اعيش المشاهد بجد جوه الحاله فعلا لا
المره دي ظبطها خليني اقول لك على تعليق
اخر برضه بيتكرر اسمك على التتر بيتكرر ست
مرات يا محمد
لا هو هو مش بيتكرر ست مرات هو عشان انا
مخرج وعامل القصه وعامل السيناريو والحوار
انا ومهاب فيعني طيب
وفي الاخر اكتب قصه احمد نجيب بس انت
بتحطه في الاول وبترجع
انا بعمل كده من ادم اوكي لاني احيانا في
رمضان لما بتكتر الاعلانات بيتقص التتر هو
لما بيتقص بيتبقى منه بياخده الى الجزء
الاولاني هي الجزء الاخير انما هو مش
موجود دايما طول الوقت وبعدين انا بقعد
اعمل في المسلسل بشتغل عليه تقريبا سبع
ثمان شهور ما بيتبقاش ليا فيه غير اسم
اللي على التتر فمش عارف ايه حد في وجود
القسم بس تمام
كتير شويه عشان انا بعمل ثلاث حاجات في
المسلسل لا حلو حلو خلص مسلسل برضو يلا حط
اسمك فين ما تبغى فيه ههه محمد كمان واحده
من الاشي امي بتفرح يعني امي اكتر حاجه
بتفرحها هي وابويا الاسم ده
عشر مرات هكتبه اذا نحط طول المسلسل حط
تحت كده على الجنب طول الوقت المسلسل مفيش
مشاكل الله يخليك يا رب ويفرحهم فيك دائما
طيب محمد كمان واحده من الاشياء كانوا صار
في احتفال واجتمعتوا كلكم انتم نجوم العمل
وكان واضح الانسجام والحب بينكم بس كان في
غياب للنجمه زينه وقيل انه في خلافات في
خلافات
هو ما كانش فيه احتفال هو ده كان
السحور دعينا الى السحور بتاع شركه
الانتاج
والله من الحاجات اللي بسطتني قوي ان احنا
لما دخلنا السحور لقينا احتفاء زمايلنا في
المسلسلات الاخرى بينا ولقينا احتفاء من
الصحافه واحتفاء من الناس فما بتدخلي
بتحسي يعني احنا كنا تقريبا مش عارف يوم
اربعه رمضان او ثلاثه رمضان او رمضان يعني
لسه احنا لسه في الاول بس حسينا بفرحه
الناس بالمسلسل وحسينا بفرحه زمايلنا لينا
فرحتنا لهم
فتحول الشكل العام الى احتفال من الناس
بينا والله وبعدين رمضان خلينا نتفق ان
رمضان وجوده بيعمل حاله برده بصراحه
واستاذه هاله صدقي ومي و و و وايمان ومنه
فضالي واحمد داش وفاهيم واحمد عبد الله
ونش كلنا كنا موجودين
فكره ان رمضان بيغني كمان فبقى المايك
راحوا للناس ادوا المايك لرمضان فبقى
رمضان بيغني فحسوا الناس ان هو احتفال
انما احنا كنا في السحور بتاع شركه
الانتاج
[موسيقى]
خلاص مش عايز تضيف اضافه تانيه على اللي
بدات فيه انا السؤال
انا اسف معلش كان ايه السؤال كان فين زين
زين زعلانه منكم فعلا في خلاف ولا لا لا
ما اعرفش لا ما اعرفش والله هي انا معرفش
ممكن تكون عندها حاجه او ممكن تكون مش
موجوده انا معرفش يعني ايه هو هو بيدعو كل
واحد مننا لشخص يعني كل واحد يوصل له
لشخصه ممكن تبقى تغير الظروف
اه انت انت شخصيا ما بينك وبين اخي يعني
لا طبعا ليه خلاف ليه اعوذ بالله بالعكس
يعني الست بطلت مسلسلي وعامله شغل جميل
جدا وانا مبسوط بالشغل ولا بالعكس ليه كان
في خلاف اعوذ بالله الحقيقه صراحه يا محمد
انت يعني يوميا بنستنى الحلقه يعني فعليا
ما ببالغ يعني رائع رائع رائع المسلسل
مسلي بشكل
رهيب وصراحه كل الكاست رائع بلغهم كلهم
تحياتنا وتحيه كبيره كبيره لصف تحديدا
يعني كمان
يا استاذاتنا الكبيره اللي تشرفنا بيها
وتشرفنا بالشغل معاه رائع رائع كلكم
رائعين في المسلسل احنا مستنيين الاحداث
طبعا كيف حتصير في النهايه بشكرك جدا يا
محمد على ظهورك معنا اليوم وانك شكرا انا
كمان يعني اخترت انا وطلعت معنا في
تفاعلكم وكل التوفيق في كل الاعمالك كان
معنا طبعا النجم المخرج محمد سامي من
القاهره شكرا لك